an internet Firestorm undertake no
prisoner's stance as James Gunn's hard
reset to the DC Universe really the best
move for the characters and fans the
ongoing chaos of Warner Brothers
Discovery and his DC Studios division
has sucked the oxygen from much of this
year's entertainment news cycle but
there seemed to be hope that the
franchise could find a way forward when
in October James Gunn and Peter saffron
were tapped to lead Warner's new DC film
and TV division since taking the role a
gun and saffron have been cleaning house
at DC Studios promising to build the
franchise Anew from the ground up gun
and saffron most recently shoved fans by
removing Henry Cavill from the role of
Superman a role the British actor has
played since 2013's Man of Steel the
decision was especially abrupt given
that kavel himself would announce to be
back in the cave he even handed his
other fun favorite role as geralt of
Rivier on Netflix's The Witcher over to
Liam Hemsworth
[Music]
I thought the world needed me too the
departure of Kabul who has long been
regarded as one of the bright spots of
the former dceu seems to have been the
final straw for many but according to
Gunn he and saffron are paying the
naysayers no heed and he plans to forge
on with his vision for the DC Universe
on his personal Twitter accounts on
December 19 2022 James Gunn defended
recent decisions made alongside co-head
of DC Studios beta saffron in a series
of tweets saying the pair new in advance
how controversial their hard reset of
the franchise might be and blaming the
bulk of the outrage levied at them on
internet trials one of the things Peter
and I were aware of when we took the job
as heads of DC Studios was a certain
minority of people online that could be
well uproarious and unkind to say the
least while acknowledging the
uncertainty of the future don't
proclaimed that he and saffron have the
best interest of the franchise at heart
noting our choices for the DCU are based
upon what we believe is best for the
story and best for the DC characters who
have been around for nearly 85 years
perhaps these choices are great perhaps
not but they are made with sincere
hearts and integrity and always with the
story in mind goon added that he and
saffron knew what they were walking into
and that they'd anticipated some initial
turbulence when making difficult
decisions about the DCU franchise it is
possible that fanango or melee was gun
and suffering there are future plans for
DC studios in the coming days and months
a new lineup of projects for fans to
look forward to would prove at the least
that there are strong hands at the helm
in his Twitter thread defending the
recent decisions at DC Studios James
Gunn also made a veiled reference to his
personal experience with online
harassment in the past writing no one
loves to be harassed or called names but
to be frank we've been through
significantly worse disrespectful outcry
will never ever affect our actions gun
is likely referencing a Flashpoint in
his career that occurred in 2018 when a
batch of his offensive tweets was widely
circulated online by conservative
influencers the Tweed switching included
jokes about a number of sensitive
subjects led to enough of an uproar that
Disney elected to fire gun from
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. of course
gun was eventually reinstated by the
house of mouse and has since worked on
both Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and
the recent Disney plus special
presentation the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special
gun concluded the Twitter thread with a
look toward the future taking Pride
alongside saffron in their new jobs as a
Shock Callers at DC Studios he wrote but
this means little to us in comparison to
our jobs as artists and custodians in
helping to create a wide and wonderful
future for DC the hierarchy of power has
indeed changed at DC though perhaps not
in ways that some fans expected whether
the new bosses can save the franchise
and carry it into a new era is the
question but a gun seems hopeful that he
and saffron will prove to be more
Superman than Lex Luthor
foreign